[Music]
all y'all rappers out there think y'all
hard cause what y'all been through hey
y'all check it out it was Friday night
chilling on my front lawn me and my crew
I had my bathrobe on everybody High just
watch X-Men got plenty Chicken Heads
ready for sex man monsters roll up
they're trying to talk smack don't these
numbers
[Music]
[Music]
I got shot
still standing
[Music]
still standing
[Music]
we're back to my Palace fast
now I'm the dude walking around with a
phallus cast like Wolverine I'm trying
to be a loner but they think a got an
adamantium boner what can I say they
still up on my totem pole [ __ ] get your
tongue ring away from the scrotum hole
don't know why they love it but it keeps
the ladies moistening gave half the
Honeys in the hood lead poisoning
shot
gun
but it's not still standing
[Music]
still standing
[Music]
yo they shot that food
[Music]
man damn that hurts damn video over man
videos over I'm serious man damn
maybe maybe it looks like we're back
together
and it's like nothing had ever
torn us apart
[Music]
so tonight I'm gonna hit that
[Music]
hit I try to fight back
[Music]
just get into my car and I'll take you
so far from where anyone can see
lava lava let's just walk and take it
slow in crowded places
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Music]
I'm sorry
there was an involuntary reaction
a struggle in the house using words and
Rhymes to get through hard times yeah
come on
I came from the streets but nothing in
my pockets no food no books no power in
the sockets each battle I fight a role
model and a teacher hip hop my church
every rapper a preacher
a piece from my ass my farts is my
sermons the church is your mouth where I
shoot my Holy Spirit you can take your
role models roll up my meat [ __ ]
always on the menu when I go out to eat
[Music]
but everywhere we go we don't forget the
struggles our black woman two jobs two
kids too tired to juggle up
[Music]
titties in my mouth I got titties
from a bunch of different cities
[Music]
within the darkness of the Sands of
times
[Music]
from getting to you
[Music]
true
[Music]
let the music in your heart give way to
the things that you believe
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
and the thing is
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
within the rhythms I believe
power
of wings
[Music]
would you look at the time you should
just stay ahead of night I've had too
much
maybe just stay where you are back to my
place you can't escape from My Embrace
that is what they all say you're hurting
my eyes
[Applause]
[Music]
[ __ ] you are mine tonight
[Music]
please just please go away you wanted me
to stay well I just changed my mind
please just be kind to know how your
mind to
you
[Music]
[Applause]
got a pocket full of funky with a
peppermint twists
[Music]
[Music]
Gonna Get It Up
[Applause]
[Music]
I'm crazy
[Music]
we're gonna
put it down
[Music]
[Music]
somebody
[Music]
door laser currency
[Music]
man I got no idea man I'm just hungry
and talking about the Galaxy and trains
I think they buying it though
[Applause]
one at a time
I put men like you behind bars every day
you may take my years
but cannot lock my soul away
all the years
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
come from I have no idea
[Music]
[Music]
now this is just a joke
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
and we speak
[Music]
is the city on fire what's with all the
smoke
oh now we're all ears
ready
[Music]
well tonight we gonna party till the
party don't stop and the party don't
stop because it keeps on going non-stop
gonna party all night gonna keep this
party going cause the party won't stop
it's been two straight days
[Music]
all my friends drinks in the back
cell phone rings iPad Facebook Party
Time skin tight jeans Friday nights
dance dance dance
[Music]
San Diego Phoenix Austin Fort Worth
Boston Memphis Denver Portland Vegas
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
New York City LA Chicago Houston Philly
San Diego Phoenix Austin Fort Worth
Boston Memphis Denver Portland Vegas
Tucson Fresno Akron Tampa Pittsburgh
newer Plano Lincoln love it Durham Salem
Dayton City
city city
[Music]
so tonight we're gonna party till the
Party Don't Stop what do you think it is
hey what's up y'all
hey what you guys playing Oh no just a
little DVD right uh what DVD uh it came
for you in the mail it says to my fresh
dope son from MC mom
come on
man
oh God please man did you produce this
track
I'm the m to the C to the m-o-m and when
it comes to Mom rappers I'm the biggity
best of them wow
his name's Carl Stewart but to me he's
just son
word up oh
okay she got that running man down can
we please turn this off
you left some stuff behind that I can
send you if you need Like Your Best
Friend Bear and your magazines going
through all this stuff but it looks
pretty risky you use so much lotion but
your socks sure are crispy
I've been cleaning with the broom and
the vacuum and found Victoria's Secret
is she's hiding in your room every nook
and cranny there are lots of tissue I
can't even open this swimsuit issue
what is wrong with you bro I spilled a
soda on that magazine I'm getting your
sheets so nice and clean like when you
wet your bed till you were 16. I
overreacted sorry I spent you look
another crispy sock no thank you
how many crispy socks she gonna find
though crispy socks here crispy socks
there crispy sucks with some mystery
hair we're gonna turn it off right now
come on you guys we started it we gonna
finish
[Music]
oh oh the beat changed up
I got the kitchen and the basement and
the living room and since his dad met
that [ __ ] I got his office too got my
juices going my Rhymes flowing my breath
blowing showing the signs are slowing I
can feel my skills growing took a little
practice to practice these lyrical
gymnastics but now the fact is Queen Bee
imma be throwing out your mattress hell
yeah baddest [ __ ] in the biz taking the
show on the road you can clean up your
own jizz
peace
there's some change
sorry man I got nothing
all right
hold it right there
foreign
are you talking back to me no I was just
walking look there is no reason for you
to get upset sir I'm not I'm not all
right that's it put your hands on your
head put my hands up put your hands on
your head yes
that's your chance
[Music]
I just asked you like politely what it
is that I did I think I was born
yesterday come on man get in the car
duck your head
ah
[Music]
all right Officer I'll take it from here
[Music]
oh hi Wally good to see you
he's all yours
all right
y'all have a good night all right thanks
man but where we go I'm glad you asked
follow me do that
all right
whoa
look at this place
where are we just be patient and I'll
show you your suit change follow me to a
place I know it ain't no pain ain't no
sorrow it's a place to be if your skin
is brown
I'm talking about negro time
negro time
what like Atlanta
almost now be quiet while I sing in
negro town you can walk the street
without getting stopped harassed or
beaten there's always a cab when you
need to get around
and they always stops
[Music]
won't get followed when you try to shop
[Music]
the white folks to cross the street in
fears
shape
and there's no white pictures to take
them away
sounds too good to be true it does
doesn't it but can I finish the song oh
I mean cam I'm finished I'm sorry I'm
sorry in any good town you live long and
well there's no disease no sickle cell
no stupid ass white folks touching your
hair or stealing your culture claiming
in stairs
[Music]
hanging out in the groove doesn't make
you a game every word that you say ain't
considered saying no one trying to get
in on the latest Trend by making you
they're talking black friends it's the
place where Harmony is found he's a
mother
[Music]
around me baby girl
[Music]